good morning again it's tuesday i want
to talk about racism today but i'm
already pretty nervous because one i am
definitely not an expert and two
racism is big and complex and nuanced in
the internet
god bless it doesn't really specialize
in nuance
but a bunch of recent surveys have shown
that around 75 percent of white
americans do not think that there is
racial bias in the criminal justice
system and the slight majority of white
americans don't think that racism is a
significant problem in america but so
far as i can tell
whether systemic bias against african
americans exists in the united
states is not really a debatable point
so i want to look today
at some data okay let's begin with the
criminal justice system so last year the
u.s sentencing commission released a
report showing that african-american
men's prison sentences were on average
20 percent longer than white men's
prison sentences when they were
convicted of similar crimes
and in fact in the past decade the
racial gap in sentencing has been
widening
also black people and white people use
illegal drugs at almost identical rates
but black people are three times more
likely to be arrested for drug
possession also african americans are
far more likely to be stopped and
searched by police at least in the
jurisdictions that keep good records
even though in many cases the contraband
hit rate the chance that an officer will
find something actually illegal
is higher among white people by the way
there's links about all this stuff in
the doobly-doo but there's just so much
i mean people convicted of crimes and
then later exonerated by dna evidence
are disproportionately black black kids
are more likely to be tried as adults
than white kids and more likely to be
sentenced to life in prison and even
after released black former inmates are
less likely to get callbacks from
potential employers than white former
inmates regardless of the crime
committed speaking of which let's turn
to the job market so one of the things
that makes it so hard to isolate race
when trying to study it is that so many
other factors are at work in systemic
injustice right like there's class and
health and wealth none of which are
fully separable from race
but okay so a large 2004 university of
chicago study submitted
thousands of resumes to a huge variety
of employers and all the resumes were
completely identical
except for the applicant's name it could
be emily or brendan or lakeisha or jamal
and lakisha
and jamal got 50 fewer callbacks than
emily and brendan despite having
literally identical resumes hank i'm
pretty sure that's about race
in fact studies consistently show racial
bias and employment and hiring in the
u.s and also around the world but i only
have four minutes of links in the do we
do in education again
the evidence of systemic bias is pretty
overwhelming for instance among american
high schools with mostly black and
latino students only 74
offer algebra 2 as a class just 66
offer chemistry the percentages for
mostly white schools are much higher
when it comes to health care you could
write a book about racial bias and in
fact people have but i'll just quote
from an american college of physicians
report from 2010
overwhelming evidence shows that racial
and ethnic minorities are prone to poor
quality healthcare than white americans
even when factors such as insurance
status are controlled and as the report
points out by some measures including
life expectancy which is really the
ultimate measure the disparity has been
increasing for decades now i want to be
clear that most of this research
establishes correlations which isn't the
same thing as causation like certainly
the tremendous economic inequality right
now in the united states is a factor in
racial disparities but then of course
race also factors into class and
economic status like for instance much
of the racial wealth disparity in the us
is due to inheritance white people are
far more likely to inherit money and
land than black people are
and that's due in large part to the fact
that for almost all of american history
it was basically impossible for african
americans to accrue wealth now hey i'm
obviously just scratching the surface
here but to deny the existence of
systemic racism is to deny
a huge body of evidence indicating that
racial bias affects
almost every facet of american life hey
the last thing i want to say is that
well i think statistics and data are
really important i also think it's
important to listen to the voices of
people who have been affected by racism
data is cold in a way that humans are
not and to really
understand these statistics and their
impact on the real lives of real people
we need to find ways to listen to those
people hank put together a playlist and
some links in the doobly-doo as a start
hank
i'll see you on friday